if you already had the disease you have
natural immunity don't you know people
have had Co four or five times I do
that's not natural immunity probably
because you had too many vaccines I
didn't have Co did you did the vaccine
gave you co statistically you you still
have a 90% better chance of not being
hospitalized not dying if you're
vaccinated well that but that's assuming
all people are alike and that is one of
the giant fallacies in your way of
thinking we are not all alike what's the
cost of getting a vaccine what's well
the fact that you the fact that you
don't even have a clue what's the cost
of getting vaccine that you don't know
the answer to that you completely want
to shut your eyes to the fact that there
are repercussions to all medical
interventions I'm not against doing
vaccines I'm against doing vaccines that
I don't think I need I should be able to
decide that for myself inside my body
when he ask what's the cost of getting a
vaccine there are undoubtedly at least
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
people all over the world who have been
vaccine injured why would you just press
the system